The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's start.
Any questions?
We've been gradually building
up thermodynamics, culminating
in what I call the most
important fundamental relation,
which was the E is
T dS plus Ji dxi.
And essentially
we said that this
was some statement of
conservation of energy.
where there's a heat component
that goes into the system,
and there's a work component.
And actually, we ended up
breaking the work component
into a mechanical part
and a chemical part,
which we wrote as
mu alpha dN alpha.
I guess if I don't
write the sums,
the summation
convention is assumed.
Now, this gave us an idea of
what a thermodynamic system is,
in the sense of how many
coordinates do we need in order
to place the system
in equilibrium
somewhere in some
coordinate space.
And we said that we can just
count the number of variables
that we have on this side.
And indeed, for
the case of energy,
the natural set of variables
would be S, x, and N.
And given some place in
the coordinate system that
is S, x, and N, you
could find a point that
corresponds to that
thermodynamic equilibrium
state.
Now, having gotten this
fundamental relation,
we can manipulate and write
it in different fashion.
And in particular,
for example, you
can write the S is dE by
dT, minus Ji dxi over T,
minus mu alpha dN alpha over
T. So you could in principle
express everything rather than
in terms of entropy-- which
in some circumstances may not
be the right variable-- in terms
of the energy content of
the system and the variables
that you need in order to
make work type of changes
on the system.
And we saw that other
versions of it is possible.
So for example, we
could rearrange.
Rather than looking
at E, we could
look at E minus TS, the
quantity that we call F.
And then dF would look very
much like the original equation.
Rather than T dS, we
would get minus S dT.
And clearly, for
this quantity F,
the natural variables
are T, x, and N.
And there were other
types of these functions
that we construct.
So basically at this stage, we
have a formula that tells us
how to navigate our way
in this space of things
that are in equilibrium.
And by taking various
derivatives of equilibrium
functions with
respect to each other,
we can express other ones.
And via this methodology, we can
relate to many different things
to each other and have
mathematical relations
between physical observables.
So following up on
that, we then ask
what are some other mathematical
forms that we can look at.
And one set of forms
followed from extensivity.
And we saw that if we were
under circumstances such
that we were to multiply all
of the extensive variables
by some factor-- 2, 3,
whatever-- and the energy
content would increase
by that same factor,
then we could in fact
integrate the equation
and drop the d's and
write it in this fashion--
TS Jx plus mu N, regarding
these as kind of vectors.
And importantly, that told us
that the intensive variables
were not independent
of each other.
And you had relationship that
you-- S dT plus Ji xi dJi
plus N alpha d mu alpha is 0.
And last time, I
did one calculation
using this Gibbs-Duhem
relation that I repeat.
And that was for a gas isotherm.
Isotherm corresponds
to dT goes to 0.
And the analogue of hydrostatic
work for a gas was minus P
for J. So this becomes
minus V dP plus N d mu.
If you have one
component, it goes to 0.
And we said that this
gives us the relationship
along an isotherm.
So for a fixed T, d
mu by dP is V over N.
I'll come back to that shortly.
Towards the end
of last lecture, I
mentioned that we
can get a number
of other so-called
Maxwell relations
by noting that mixed
second derivatives are
independent of the order
of taking derivatives.
So that if you have some df
of x and y written as df by dx
at constant y dx, plus df
by dy at constant x dy,
then the order of the
second derivatives, which
would be obtained
by taking either
a derivative of the
first term with respect
to y or the second term
with respect to x--
doesn't matter which order.
So let's start with
our initial equation.
And for simplicity,
let's think of cases
where we have a fixed
number of particles
so that we can write
dE as T dS plus Ji dxi.
So this looks like this dF
that I wrote before for you.
And I can identify temperature
as dE by dS at constant x,
and each one of the forces Ji
as dE by dxi at constant S.
And all of the J's that are
not equal to i kept fixed.
And then, since the
second derivative
is irrespective of order, I
can form the second derivative
with respect to the combination
S xi into a different fashion.
I can either take a derivative
over here-- I already
have derivative with
respect to S giving me T,
so I will get dT by dxi,
essentially at constant S--
or I can take the
derivative of this object.
I already have the x derivative,
so I take the S derivative.
So I have dJi with respect
to S at constant x.
So this is an example
of the Maxwell relation.
And just to remind
you, we can always
invert these derivatives.
So I can invert this
and say that actually,
if I had wondered how
the entropy changes
as a function of a force such
as pressure at constant x,
it would be related to how
the corresponding displacement
to the force changes as a
function of temperature.
So you would have a relationship
between some observable
such as how the length
of a wire changes
if you change
temperature rapidly,
and how the entropy would change
as a function of pressure,
or corresponding force,
whatever it may be.
Now, what I would like to
remind you is that the best
way to sort of derive
these relationships
is to reconstruct
what kind of second
derivative or mixed
derivative you
want to have to give
you the right result.
So for example, say
somebody told me
that I want to calculate
something similar-- dS by dJ,
let's say at
constant temperature.
How do I calculate that?
A nice way to calculate
that is if I somehow
manipulate so that S appears
as a first derivative.
Now, S does not appear as
a first derivative here,
but certainly appears as
a first derivative here.
So who says I have to take
E as a function of state?
I can look at the
second derivative of F.
So if I look at F,
which is E minus TS--
and actually, I don't
even need to know
what the name of this entity is,
whether it's F, G, et cetera.
All I know is that it will
convert this to minus S dT--
the TS that I don't want,
so that S appears now
as a first derivative.
Now I want to take a
derivative of S with respect
to J. If I just stop here, the
next term that I would have
is Ji dxi.
And the natural way that I would
construct a second derivative
would give me dS
with respect to xi.
But I want the S
with respect to Ji.
So I say, OK, I'll do
this function instead.
As I said, I don't
really care what
the name of these functions is.
This will get
converted to xi dJ.
Now I can say there is
this first derivative-- d o
minus S with respect
to Ji at constant T
is the same thing as d
of minus y with respect
to T at constant J. So I can
get rid of the minus sign
if I want, and I have
the answer that I want.
It is dxi by dT at constant
J-- at constant-- yeah, T-- J.
And you can go and construct
anything else that you like.
Let me, for example,
try to construct
this entity we
already calculated.
So let's see.
What can I say about d mu by
dP at constant temperature,
and I want to calculate
that via a Maxwell relation?
So what do I know?
I know that dE is
T dS minus pdV.
Good.
Oh, I want to have
mu in the play,
so now I have to add mu dN.
That's good, because I have
mu as a first derivative.
I have it over here.
But I have P as a
first derivative,
whereas I want P to appear as
the work element, something
like dP.
So what I will do is I will
make this d of E plus pV.
This converts this to
plus V dP plus mu dN.
That's fine, except that
when I do things now,
I would have calculated
things at constant S.
And I want to calculate
things at constant T.
That's not really important.
I do a minus ST. This
becomes minus S dT.
And then I have a
function of state--
I don't care what
it's called-- that has
the right format for me
to identify that d mu
by dP at constant N and T,
along an isotherm of a fixed
number of particles,
is the same thing as dV
by dN at constant PN T. So
that's my Maxwell relation.
So why didn't I get this result?
Did I make a mistake?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Louder.
AUDIENCE: Is this valid
for extensive systems?
PROFESSOR: Yes, this is
valid for extensive system.
I used extensively in
the relation of this.
And here, I never
used extensivity.
But if I have a system that
I tell you its pressure
and temperature, how
is its volume related
to the number of particles?
I have a box in this room.
I tell you pressure and
temperature are fixed.
If I make the box twice as big,
number of particles, volume
will go twice as big.
So if I were to
apply extensivity,
I would have to conclude that
this is the same thing as V
over N, and I would
be in agreement
with what I had before.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What about the
constraint of constant PN T
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Actually, constraint
of constant PN T
is important because
we said that said there
it is a kind of
Gibbs-Duhem relation.
And the Gibbs-Duhem
relation tells me
for the case of the gas that
the S dT minus V dP plus N d mu
is 0.
And that constraint
is the one that
tells me that once you have
set P and T, which are the two
variables that I have specified
here, you also know mu.
That is, you know all
the intensive quantities.
So once you set PN T-- the
constraints over there--
really, the only thing
that you don't know
is how big the system is.
And that's what's the condition
that I used over here.
But it is only-- so
let me re-emphasize
it this way-- I
will write dV by dN
is the same thing as V over
N, only if I have PN T here.
If I had here PN S, for example,
I wouldn't be able to use this.
I was going to
build this equation
to say, look at the
elements of this.
This part we got
from the first law,
the temperature we got
from the zeroth law,
and this we got from the
second law, which is correct,
but it leaves out
something, which
is that what the second
law had was things
going some particular direction.
And in particular, we had
that for the certain changes
that I won't repeat, the change
in entropy to be positive.
So when you are in
equilibrium, you
have this relationship between
equilibrium state functions.
But in fact, the second
law of thermodynamics
tells you a little
bit more than that.
So the next item that
we are going to look at
is, what are the
consequences of having
underlying this equality
between functions
of state some kind of an
inequality about certain things
being possible and things
not being possible?
And that relates to
stability conditions.
And I find it easier to
again introduce to you these
stability conditions by thinking
of a mechanical analogue.
So let's imagine that you
have some kind of a spring,
and that this spring has some
kind of a potential energy
that I will call phi as a
function of the extension x.
And let's say that it's
some non-linear function
such as this.
There is no reason why we
should use a hook and spring,
but something like this.
Now, we also discussed
last time what
happens if I were to pull
on this with some force J.
So I pull on this.
As a result, presumably
it will no longer
be sitting at x, because
what I need to do
is to minimize something else--
the function that we call H--
which was the potential
energy of the spring
plus the entity that
was exerting the force.
So if I were to make it
in the vertical direction,
you can imagine this as
being the potential energy
of the mass that was
pulling on the spring.
So what that means is
that in the presence of J,
what I need to do is
to find the x that
minimizes this expression.
Once essentially the kinetic
energy has disappeared,
my spring stops oscillating
and goes to a particular value.
And mathematically,
that corresponds
to subtracting a linear
function from this.
Actually, what
will it look like?
Let's not make this go flat,
but go up in some linear fashion
so that at least I can
draw something like this.
So what I need to do
is to minimize this.
So I find that for
a given J, I have
to solve d phi dx equals J.
But especially if you have
a spring that has the kind of
potential that I drew for you,
you start increasing
the-- so basically,
what it says is that
you end up at the place
where the slope is
equal to the derivative
of the potential function.
What happens if you start
increasing this slope,
if it is a non-linear type
of thing, at some point
you can see it's impossible.
Essentially, it's like
a very flat noodle.
You pull on it too much and then
it starts to expand forever.
So essentially, this thing that
we are looking for a minimum,
ultimately also
means that you need
to have a condition on
the second derivative.
d2 phi by dx squared better
be positive actually,
I have to take d2
H y dx squared.
I took one derivative
to identify
where the location of
the best solution is.
If I take a second
derivative, this
became essentially the
J. J is a constant.
It only depends on
the potential energy.
So it says independent of
the force that you apply.
You know that if the shape of
the potential energy is given,
the only places
that are accessible
are the kinds of
places where you
take the second
derivative and the second
has a particular sign.
So this portion of the
curve is in principle
physically accessible.
The portion that corresponds
to essentially changing
the curvature and going the
other way, there's no way,
there's no force
that you can put
that would be able to access
those kinds of displacements.
So there is this
convexity condition.
This was for one variable.
Now suppose you have multiple
variables-- x2, x3, et cetera.
So you will have
the potential energy
as a function of many variables.
And the condition that you have
is that the second derivative
of the potential with respect
to all variables, which forms--
and if there are n variables,
this would be an n by n matrix.
This matrix is
positive definite.
What that means is
that if you think
of this as defining for you
the bottom of a potential,
in whatever direction
you go, this
would describe the change
of potential for you.
The first order
change you already
set to 0 because of the force J.
The second order change better
be positive.
So this is the condition that
you would have for stability,
quite generally mechanically.
And again, this
came from the fact
that if you were
to exert a force,
you would change the energy
by something like J delta
x, which is certainly the
same thing that we have here.
This is just one component
that I have been focusing on.
And so ultimately,
I'm going to try
to generalize that to this form.
But one thing that I don't
quite like in this form
is that I'm focusing too
much on the displacements.
This is written appropriately
using this form.
And we have seen over
here that whether or not
I express things in terms
of the displacements
or in terms of entropy,
temperature, conjugate forces,
et cetera, these are
all equivalent ways
of describing the
equilibrium system.
So I'm going to do a
slight manipulation of this
to make that symmetry between
forces and displacements
apparent.
So the generalization
of this expression
that we have over
here is that once I
know the potential
energy, the force
in this multi-component
space is df by dxi.
So in this multi-component
space, I have some J,
and there's a corresponding x.
They're related by this.
Now, if I were to
make a change in J,
there will be a change in the
position of the equilibrium.
And I can get that by
doing a corresponding cange
in the derivative.
The corresponding
change in the derivative
is the second derivative
of phi with respect
to xi xj delta xj, sum
over J. So what I'm saying
is that this is a
condition that relates
the position to the forces.
If I make a slight
change in the force,
there will be a corresponding
slight change in the position.
And the changes in the
position and the force given
by this equilibrium condition
are related by this formula.
Now, you can see that that
sum is already present here.
So I can rewrite
the expression that
is over here using that
formula as delta xi delta
Ji, sum over i--
better be positive.
So this expression is slightly
different and better way
of writing essentially the same
convexity condition, stability
condition, but in a
manner that treats
the displacements and
the forces equivalently.
And I'm going to
apply that to this
and say that in
general, there will
be more ways of
manipulating the energy
of a thermodynamic system, and
that having the system reach
to equilibrium requires
the generalization of this
as a delta T delta S, plus
sum over i delta Ji delta xi,
plus sum over alpha,
delta mu alpha,
delta N alpha-- to be positive.
And you may say I didn't
really derive this for you
because I started from
mechanical equilibrium
and stability condition
and generalized
to the thermodynamic one.
But really, if you go back
and I use this condition
and do manipulations that
are compatible to this,
you will come up with exactly
this stability condition.
And I have that in the notes.
It is somewhat more
mathematically complicated
than this, because the
derivatives involve
additional factors
of 1 over T. And you
have to do slightly more
work, but you will ultimately
come with the same expression.
OK?
You say, why is that of any use?
It is possible
that you've already
seen a particular use
of this expression.
Let's look at the case
of a gas-- one component.
You would say that the
condition that we have
is that delta T delta S minus
delta P delta V plus delta mu
delta N has to be positive.
Let's even be simpler.
Look at the case
where delta T is 0,
delta N equals to 0, which
means that I have a fixed
amount of gas at a
particular temperature.
So I could have,
for example, a box
in this room which
is in equilibrium
at the same temperature as
the temperature of the room.
But its volume I'm
allowed to adjust
so that the pressure changes.
So in that process, at a
particular temperature,
I will be finding a particular
curve in the pressure volume
space.
And the reason that I
drew this particular way
is because I have the condition
that minus dP dV better
be positive, so that if I
have P as a function of V,
then I know that dP
is dP by dV delta V.
And if the product
dP dV is positive,
then this derivative dP
by dV has to be negative.
This has to be a
decreasing function.
And another way
of saying that is
that the compressibility--
kappa T, which is minus 1
over V, the inverse of this
dV by dP at constant T--
has to be positive.
So this is a curve where
dP by dV is negative.
Fine, you say.
Nothing surprising about that.
Well, it turns out that
if you cool the gas,
the shape of this
isotherm can change.
It can get started.
And there is a critical
isotherm at which
you see a condition such
as this, where there's
a point where the curve
comes with 0 slope.
So you say that for that
particular critical isotherm
occurring at TC, if I were
to make this expansion,
the first term in
this expansion is 0.
You say, OK, let's continue and
write down the second term--
1/2 d2 P by dV squared
at constant P times
delta V squared.
Now the problem is
that if I multiply this
by delta V-- which would have
made this into delta V squared
and then this into
delta V cubed--
I have a problem
because delta V can
be both positive or negative.
I can go one direction
or the other direction.
And a term that is a
cubic can change sign--
can sometimes be positive,
can sometimes be negative,
depending on the sign of that.
And that is disallowed
by this condition.
So that would say that if
an analytical expression
for the expansion exists, the
second derivative has to be 0.
And then you would have
to go to the next term-- d
cubed P dV cubed.
And then delta V-- you would
normally write delta V cubed,
but then I've multiplied by
delta V on the other side.
We'd have delta V to the fourth.
Delta V to the fourth you would
say is definitely positive.
Then I can get things done
by having to make sure
that the third
derivative is negative.
And you say, OK, exactly
what have you done here?
What you have done
here is you've
drawn a curve that
locally looks like a cubic
with the appropriate sign.
And so that's certainly
true that if you
have an isotherm there the
compressibility diverges,
you have a condition
on second derivatives.
And you probably have used this
for calculating critical points
of van der Waals
and other gases.
And we will do that ourselves.
But it's actually not the
right way to go about,
because when you go and look
at things experimentally
with sufficient detail, you find
that these curves at this point
are not analytic.
They don't admit a
Taylor expansion.
So while this
condition is correct,
that the shape should
be something like this,
it is neither cubic
nor a fifth power,
but some kind of a
non-analytic curve.
AUDIENCE: Could you
repeat last statement?
PROFESSOR: That
statement, in order
to fully understand
and appreciate,
you have to come
to next term, where
we talk about phase transitions.
But the statement
is that the shape
of the function in the
vicinity of something like this
is delta P is
proportional to delta V
to some other gamma that is
neither 3 nor 5 nor an integer.
It is some number
that experimentally
has been determined to be of
the order of, I don't know, 4.7.
And why it is 4.7 you have to
do a lot of interesting field
theory to understand.
And hopefully, you'll come next
semester and I'll explain it.
AUDIENCE: So your point is
that gamma is not [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Gamma is not-- so
the statement is, in order
for me to write this
curve as something delta V
plus some other thing--
delta V Squared--
plus some other
thing-- delta V cubed--
which we do all the time,
there is an inherent assumption
that an analytical expansion
is possible around this point.
Whereas if I gave you a
function y that is x to the 5/3,
around x of 0, you cannot
write a Taylor series for it.
OK?
Essentially, this
stability condition
tells you a lot of things about
signs of response functions.
In the case of
mechanical cases, it
is really that if
you have a spring,
you better have a force
constant that is positive,
so that when you pull on it,
the change in displacement
has the right sign.
It wants to be contracted.
And similarly here,
you are essentially
compressing the gas.
There's a thermal analogue of
that sine which is worth making
sure we know.
Let's look at the
case where we have
a fixed number of particles.
And then what we would
have is that our dE
is T dS plus Ji dxi.
I am free to choose
any set of variables.
The interesting set of
variables-- well, OK.
So then stability implies
that delta T delta
S plus delta Ji delta xi with
the sum over i is positive.
Now, I can take a look
at this expression
and choose any set of variables
to express these changes
in terms of.
So I'm going to choose for my
variables temperature and xi.
You see, the way that
I've written it here,
S, T, J, x appear
completely equivalently.
I could have chosen
to express things
in terms of S and
J, T and J, S and x.
But I choose to use T and x.
All right, so what
does that mean?
It means that I write my
delta S in terms of dS
by dT at constant x dT,
plus dS by dxi at constant T
and other xj not
equal to i, delta xi.
I also need an expression
for delta Ji here.
so my delta Ji
would be dJi by dT
at constant x, delta T,
plus dJi with respect
to xj at constant T, an
appropriate set of J's,
delta xi-- delta xj.
Sum over J implicit here.
I substitute these--
delta S and delta J--
in the general form of
the stability condition
to get constraints
applicable to combinations
involving delta T and delta x.
So I have to multiply
delta S with delta T.
I have to multiply delta
Ji with delta xi here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So here,
J is not equal to i.
And then which one is J?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's say that I have S
that is a function of-- I
have x1 and x2.
So here, I would
have derivatives
dS by dx1 times delta x1.
I would have derivatives
dS by dx2 times delta x2.
In both cases, T is kept fixed.
In this case, additionally,
x2 is kept fixed.
x1 is kept fixed.
That's all.
OK?
So let's do that multiplication.
We multiply a delta T here and
we get dS by dT at constant x,
delta T squared.
We get here a term which is
delta T delta xi, multiplying
dS by dxi at constant
T, and the others
that I don't bother to write.
But I note that I will
get another term that
is delta xi delta t from the
second term, whose coefficient
is dJi by dT at constant x.
And I group those
two terms together.
And finally, we have
the last term here,
which is delta xi delta
xj, dJi by dxj, constant T.
And the constraint for all
of these stability conditions
that I have written,
I have to be
in the minimum of a potential.
Any deviation that
I make better lead
to an increase in this
combination, which
is kind of equivalent
to being at the minimum
of some kind of
potential energy.
If you do some
manipulations, this
is also equivalent to
being at the maximum
of some entropy function.
Now, let's look at that
manipulation a little bit.
Now, I happen to know
that this form will
simplify a little bit.
And that's why I chose this
combination of variables.
And the simplification
that will happen
is that this entity is 0.
So let me show you
why that entity is 0.
And that relies on one of
these Maxwell relationships
that I had.
So let's find the
Maxwell relation that
is applicable to dS by
dxi at constant T, which
is what I have over here.
OK, let's again start with
dE being T dS plus ji dxi.
I'm at fixed number
of particles.
I don't need to write
the other term-- UDN.
Unfortunately here, S is
not the first derivative.
So what I will do is I
will look at E minus TS.
That's going to turn
this into minus S dT.
Good.
Ji dxi is exactly what I want
because this will tell me
something about the
derivative in this fashion.
dS by dxi at constant
T is equal to what?
It's taking the things
in this fashion,
which is dJi by
dT at constant x.
Good.
So I can see that the sum
total of these two terms is 0.
And that's exactly
what I have here.
So this is 0 by
Maxwell relation.
OK?
OK
So having set that to
0, I have two terms.
One of them is this entity
that goes with delta T squared.
And the other is this entity--
sum over i and J, delta xi,
delta xj, dJi, dxj,
constant T. And this--
for any choice of delta x's
and delta T's-- for any choice,
it better be positive.
So in particular,
given this nice form
that I have over
here, I can certainly
choose all of the delta x's
to be 0, because I do things
at constant displacement.
And then what I have
is that the whole thing
is proportional to delta T
squared and some coefficient.
So that coefficient
better be positive.
So entropy should always
be an increasing function
of temperature at
constant displacement.
And the consequence of that is
that heat capacities measure
at constant displacement.
So this is the
heat capacity-- Cx.
The general definition is
you put some amount of heat
into the system at
constant displacement.
So I have to specify
the procedure
by which heat is
applied to the system
and see how much this
temperature changes.
I can in principle do this
sufficiently stability
so I can measure precisely
the changes in temperature
infinitesimally.
And then I can use
the relationship
between dQ and reversible
heat-- so dS at constant x dT.
And dS by dT at constant
x is precisely the entity
that we have looked
at-- to be positive.
So in the same way that a spring
is stable-- if you pull on it,
its extension should
increase a little bit.
And so the coefficient
that relates
the change in
displacement corresponding
to the change in force has
to be positive for stability.
Heat capacities must have
this positivity in the sense
that if you add
heat to a system,
its temperature should go up.
It it went the other way, it
would actually also violate
the second law of
thermodynamics.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm a bit confused
about the J notation
that we used.
The initial equation
that we start
has only-- it deals with i,
but where does J come from?
PROFESSOR: This equation.
Which equation?
Up here?
AUDIENCE: So index J is
just a dummy variable?
[INAUDIBLE] that dE
equals T dS equals Ji dSi.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Fine.
So let's start from here.
And part of the confusion is
that I'm not really consistent.
Whenever I write an
index that is repeated,
there is a so-called
summation convention
that you may have seen
in quantum mechanics
and other courses which
says that the index that
is repeated twice
is summed over.
So when I write ai bi, using
the summation convention, what
I mean is, sum over all
possible values of i, ai, bi.
So what I meant
here is that there
may be multiple ways of
doing work on the system.
So there could be pressure,
there could be spring,
there could be magnetic work.
And if I do mechanical
work on the system,
the change in energy is the
sum total of all different ways
to do mechanical
works, plus the heat
that is supplied to the system.
So that's statement number one.
Now, I did something
else here, which
is that when I take a derivative
of a function that depends
on multiple variables-- so
f depends on x1, x2, x3,
xn-- then if I look
at the change in this,
any one of these
variables can change
by an amount that is dxi.
And if the second
variable changes,
there is a corresponding
contribution,
which is df with respect
to the second variable.
And I have to add all of
these things together.
So if I'm again
inconsistent, this
is really what I
mean, that when you
do a change in a function
of multiple variables,
you would write it
as dxi, df by dxi.
If you use the
summation convention,
I have to really sum
over all possibilities.
Now, suppose I took one of
these things, like df by dx3.
So it's one of the
derivatives here.
And I took another derivative,
or I looked at the change
in this function.
This function depends also
on variables x1 through xn.
So I have to look at the sum
over all changes with respect
to xj of df by dx3 delta xj.
So you can see that
automatically, I
have kind of assumed
some of these things
as I write things rapidly.
And if it is not clear, you have
to spend a little bit of time
writing things more in
detail, because it's
after all kind of
simple algebra.
Yes, did I make another mistake?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Oh, not
a mistake, just--
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you were
talking about mechanicals,
you had a non-linear spring.
You start pulling on it.
At some point, it
just increases.
PROFESSOR: If it is a non-linear
spring, yes, that's right.
AUDIENCE: Can you provide
example of thermodynamic system
which, upon some
threshold action upon it,
becomes unstable?
PROFESSOR: OK.
I think I more or
less had that example.
Let's try to develop it
a little bit further.
So I said that typically, if
I look at the pressure volume
isotherms of a gas, it
looks something like this.
And I told you that
there is actually
some kind of a critical isotherm
that looks something like this.
And you may ask,
well, what do things
look below that for
lower temperatures?
And again, you
probably know this,
is that this is the
temperature below which
you have a transition to
liquid gas coexistence.
And so the isotherms
would look like that.
Now, it turns out that while
these are true equilibrium
things-- you would have
to wait sufficiently long
so that the system
explores these isotherms--
it is also possible
in certain systems
to do things a little
bit more rapidly.
And then when you
go below, you will
see a kind of remnant of that
isotherm which kind of looks
like this.
So that isotherm would
have portions of it
that don't satisfy these
conditions of stability.
And the reason that you still
get some remnant of it--
not quite the entire thing.
You get actually
some portion here,
some portion here-- is because
you do things very rapidly
and the system
does not have time
to explore the
entire equilibrium.
So that's one example
that I can think
of where some remnants
of something that
is like that non-linear
noodle takes place.
But even the non-linear
noodle, you cannot really see
in equilibrium.
You can only see it
when you're pulling it.
And you can see that
it is being extended.
There is no equilibrium that
you can see that has that.
So if I want to find an analogue
of that non-linear noodle
showing instability, I'd better
find some near-equilibrium
condition.
And this is the near-equilibrium
condition that I can think of.
There are a number of cases.
And essentially, you've
probably heard hysteresis
in magnets and things like that.
And by definition,
hysteresis means
that for the same
set of conditions,
you see multiple
different states.
So not both of them can
be or multiple of them
can be in equilibrium.
And over some
sufficient time scale,
you would go from one
behavior to another behavior.
But if you explore the vicinity
of the curves that correspond
to these hysteretic
behavior, you
would see the signatures
of these kinds
of thermodynamic instabilities.
There was one other part
of this that maybe I
will write a little bit
in more detail, given
the questions that were.
Asked It is here I looked
at this general condition
for the case where
the delta x's were 0.
Let's look at the same
thing for the case
where delta T equals
to 0, because then I
have the condition that
the Ji by the xj, delta xi,
delta xj should be positive.
And this was done at constant T.
And to be more explicit, there
is a sum over i and J in here.
So if I'm doing things
at constant temperature,
I really have the analogue
of the instability condition.
What I have here, it is
the same thing as this one.
And if you think about this
in a little bit more detail--
let's say I have
something like a gas.
We have two ways of
doing work on the system.
I have dJ1 by dx1.
I have dJ2 by dx2.
I have dJ1 by dx2.
I have dj2 by dx1.
Essentially, this object,
there are four of them.
And those four I can put
into something like this.
And the statement
that I have written
is that this 2 by
2 matrix, if it
acts on the displacement delta
x1 delta x2 on the right,
and then gets contracted on the
left by the same vector delta
x1, delta x2, for any
choice of the vector delta
x1 delta x2, this
better be positive.
This is for two, but in
general, this expression
is going to be valid
for any number.
Now, what are the constraints
that a matrix must satisfy
so that irrespective of the
choice of this displacement,
you will get a positive result?
Mathematically, that's caused
a positive definite matrix.
So one of the conditions that
is certainly immediately obvious
is that if I choose the case
where delta x2 is 0, then
the diagonal term
that corresponds
to that entity
better be positive.
So a matrix is positive
definite if for every one
of the diagonal elements,
I have this condition.
So this is actually something
that we already saw.
In the case of the
gas, this would
be something like minus dP by
dV at constant temperature--
be positive.
This is the nature of
these isotherms always
going one way that
I was drawing.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You're not summing
over alpha now, are you?
Or are you--
PROFESSOR: Yes, I'm not.
And I don't know how
to write. [LAUGHS]
Let's call it delta J1, x1.
So all diagonal elements
must be positive,
but that's not enough.
So I can write a matrix that
has only positive elements
along the diagonal, but
off-diagonal elements such
that the combination
will give you
negative values of
this culmination
for appropriate choices
of delta x1 and delta x2.
The thing that
you really need is
that all eigenvalues
must be positive.
It is not that easy to
write down mathematically
in general what that means
in terms of multiple response
functions.
That's why this
form of writing is
much more compact and effective.
It basically says, no matter
what combination of elements
you choose, you are at the
bottom of the potential.
You should not be able
to go away from it.
AUDIENCE: So the
second statement
is necessary and
sufficient condition?
PROFESSOR: This statement is
necessary but not sufficient.
This statement is
equivalent to the meaning
of what is a positive
definite matrix.
It is sufficient.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there any
physical interpretation
to diagonalizing that matrix?
PROFESSOR: It depends on
the kind of the formations
that you make.
Like if I was really
thinking about a gas
where I allow some exchange
with the surface or something
else so that delta
N is not equal to 0,
the general form of this
matrix in the case where
I have pressure volume would
be something like this.
I would have minus dP by dV.
I would have d mu by dN.
I would have dP by dN.
I would have d mu by dV.
And I would have to make sure
that this matrix is positive
definite, so I know certainly
that the compressibility
by itself has to be positive.
d mu by dN also
has to be positive.
But if I allow
changes both in volume
and the number of
particles, then because
of these off-diagonal terms,
I have additional constraints.
So for appropriate
changes, it is
sufficient to look at
the diagonal terms.
But for the entire set of
possible transformations,
it's not.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you look at
different ways to do the work
on the system-- so in
this case, change volume,
change number of particles,
if you're saying forces have
different dimensions, and
if diagonalization of these
metrics corresponds to inventing
some new ways of acting
on the system which are a linear
combination of old ways like
change volume a little
and change particles--
PROFESSOR: Change the
number of particles, yes.
AUDIENCE: Those are pretty
weird manipulations,
in terms of how to
physically explain
what is diagonalization matrix.
PROFESSOR: OK.
There is a question
of dimensions,
and there's a
question of amount.
So maybe what you
are worried about
is that if I make one them
volume and the other pressure,
one is extensive,
one is intensive,
and the response
functions would have
to carry something that
is proportional to size.
But then there are
other conditions,
let's say, where all of the
variables are intensive.
And then it's moving
around in the space that
is characterized, let's say, by
pressure and chemical potential
from one point to another point.
And there is some generalized
response that you would have,
depending on which
direction you go to.
So essentially,
I could certainly
characterize various
thermodynamic functions
in this space P mu.
And what I know is that I cannot
write any function in this
two-parameter space that
would be consistent with
the thermodynamic
principles of stability.
I have to have some
kind of convexity.
So certainly, what
typically-- let's say again,
going back to my favorite
example here-- what people do
and what we will
do later on is we
specify that you have
some particular pressure
and volume of an
interacting gas.
And there is no way
that we can calculate
the thermodynamic properties
of that system exactly.
We try to construct
a free energy
as a function of
these variables.
And that free energy
will be approximate based
on some ideas.
And then we will see that that
free energy that I construct
in some places will violate
the conditions of stability.
And then I know that that free
energy that I constructed,
let's say on the assumption
that the box that I have
is uniformly covered
by some material,
that assumption is violated.
And maybe what has happened
is that part of the volume
is a liquid and part
of the volume is gas.
So we will do precisely
that exercise later on.
We will choose a
pair of variables.
We will try to construct a
free energy function out.
We make the assumption that
the box is uniformly occupied
with the gas at some density.
Based on that, we estimate its
energy, entropy, et cetera.
We construct a free
energy function out.
And then we will see that
that energy function violates
the compressibility
condition at some point.
So we know that, oh,
we made a mistake.
The assumption that it is
uniformly occupying this box
is wrong.
All right, any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: One of the
things that confuses me
about thermodynamics
in general is
the limits of its applicability.
We think of it as
being very general,
applying to many
different systems.
For example, if we
had two bar magnets
and we had the north pole
close to the south pole
of the other one, and I
thought of the magnetic field
in between, is it
conceivable to think
of that as a
thermodynamic system?
PROFESSOR: You can
think of the magnet
as a thermodynamic system.
And you can certainly
look at two of them,
including the electromagnetic
field that surrounds them.
And there would be
some conditions,
like if you were to jiggle
these things with respect
to each other-- and you would
maintain the entire thing
in a box that prevented escape
of electromagnetic waves
or heat to the outside--
that eventually
this jiggling of the two magnets
will lead to their coming
to equilibrium but at
a higher temperature.
So this is what I'm saying.
So imagine that you have-- let's
for simplicity think of, again,
one big magnet that
you don't move,
and one small magnet here that
you externally jiggle around.
And then you remove
the source of work.
You wait for a while.
And then you find
that after a while,
this thing comes
to an equilibrium.
You ask, where did that
kinetic energy go to?
You had some kinetic energy
that you had set into this,
and the kinetic
energy disappeared.
And I assume that
there are conditions
that the kinetic energy could
not have escaped from this box.
So the only thing that
could have happened
is that that kinetic
energy heated up
the air of the box, the
magnet, or whatever you have.
So thermodynamics is applicable
in that sense to your system.
Now, if you ask me, is
it applicable to having
a single electron spin
that is polarized because
of the magnetic field
and some condition
that I set it to oscillate,
then it's not applicable,
because then I know some
quantum mechanical rules that
govern this.
There may be in
some circumstances
some conservation law that says
this with oscillate forever.
If it doesn't oscillate
forever, there's
presumably a
transition matrix that
says it will admit a particular
photon of a particular energy.
And I have to ask what
happened to that photon.
So what we will see later
on is that thermodynamics
is very powerful, but it's
not a fundamental theory
in this sense that
the quantum mechanics
that governs the spins.
And the reason that this works
for the case of the magnet
is because the magnet has
billions of spins in it--
billions and billions
of spins, or whatever.
So it is the of large
numbers that ultimately
allows you to translate
the rules of motion
into a well-defined
theory that is
consistent with thermodynamics.
AUDIENCE: I know that my
question seemed off-topic.
But the reason why I asked
about this particular system
is because I would
think that it doesn't
have a positive compressibility.
Like if you pull the two
magnets apart very slowly,
the force pulling them
together decreases
instead of increasing
like with the rubber band.
PROFESSOR: OK.
It may be that you have to
add additional agents in order
to make the whole system work.
So it may be that the
picture that I had in mind
was that you have
the magnet that
is being pushed up and down.
And I really do put
a number of springs
that make sure there exists
an equilibrium position.
If there is no mechanical
equilibrium position,
then the story is not whether
or not to thermodynamic applies.
It's a question of whether or
not there is an equilibrium.
So in order for me to
talk about thermodynamics
I need to know that there
is an eventual equilibrium.
and that's why I actually recast
the answer to your question,
eventually getting rid of
the kinetic energy of this
so that I have a system
that is in equilibrium.
If there are things that
are not in equilibrium,
all bets are off.
Thermodynamics is the science of
things that are in equilibrium.
Other questions?
All right, so there is only one
minor part of our description--
rapid survey of
thermodynamics-- that is left.
And that's the third
law of thermodynamics
and that has to do something
with the behavior of things
as you go towards
the limit of the zero
of thermodynamic temperature.
And I think we will spend maybe
10, 15 minutes next lecture
talking about the third
law of thermodynamics.
Probably from my
perspective, that
is enough time with
respect towards the time
we spend on the other
laws of thermodynamics,
because as I will
emphasize to you also,
the third law of
thermodynamics is in some sense
less valid than the others.
It's certainly correct
and it is valid.
It is just that its validity
rests on other things than what
I was emphasizing
right now, which
is the large number
of degrees of freedom.
You could have a large
number of degrees
of freedom in a world
that is governed
by classic laws of physics, and
the third law of thermodynamics
would be violated.
So it is a condition
that we live
in a world that is governed by
quantum mechanics that tells us
about the third law, as
we will discuss next time.